they'll pin this whole thing on David
Copperfield by the way David Co he's
going to jail you will see David
Copperfield per walked all of these
billionaires they've mentioned Dubin and
black the Leon the Apollo guy and Glen
Dubin they'll all be fine the clintons
will be fine somehow David Copperfield
this
creep magician that me and my dad you
know we watched him make a train
disappear in the 90s mhm on television
it was kind cool do you remember that I
don't you were young but you know he did
a thing he made a train disappear and
and me and my father watched it maybe
you could find
it and I like David
Copperfield but
apparently
apparently yeah he made this train
vanish what year was this uh it looks
like are we gonna get a YouTube strike
for playing this
that's a good point or do you think
copperfield's people are distracted he's
got no problem maybe they're distracted
right now maybe copperfield's media
teams distracted and they're not going
to be reporting people playing as a
train trick I don't
know but I will tell you this apparently
David Copperfield was doing magic you
know you think when you go to a
pedophile orgy that would be all you do
but apparently the epin went the extra
mile he had like fun other things
happening mhm can you imagine being a
frustrated pedophile and you're sitting
there and you're like all right like you
know what I mean like uh I get it he's a
big comedian but you know we're here to
you know I mean that's why we took the
plane you know I mean we're all being
blackmailed and videotaped and you know
can we just get to it because like if I
if I see this guy do another card trick
I'm going to kill myself but apparently
that's what Epstein Did You Know It's
never enough just to be a pimp mhm It's
never enough to be anything by the way
this is what's interesting about life
it's one of the great human comedies
where it's never enough so you have this
guy who's a a like a pimp Jeffrey
Epstein's a pedophile pimp and everyone
coming to that island now I know the
media would disagree with my crazy
generalization right because of course
there were people that went to the
island to see the fauna and the Flora
but uh let's just say that a good 90
some odd percent of them were their kids
that's why they're going and Jeffrey
Epstein is he's created this island
pedophile Paradise for all of these
people but it's not enough because he
goes well you know he goes but I I want
them that I want them that I want this
to be a weekend they'll never forget and
he go well no you know probably even
jlan was probably like no no no darling
they they're going to love it we go we
got everything I got all these girls
we're bringing them in he goes no no no
but what if what about it a magic show
and she's I don't really we need I don't
darling I don't know if we have we've
got all these we've got all these
children from Bad homes and they're
going to they all these people and
darling they're going to love it and
he's like yeah but I just want
more I want I want people to talk about
this I don't want this just to be you
know the same old pedophile orgies that
they've always been doing Washington I
want magic magician David Copperfield
had dinner with Jeffrey Epstein and
asked victim if she realized predator's
girls were getting paid to find out
other girls for him to abuse so what is
what does this mean was Copperfield
saying this like hey what's up here this
incriminates Copperfield potentially why
or maybe he's asking because he doesn't
like this maybe maybe it's just it's you
know he but did he leave the island
after he asked this question cuz you
know he then he kind of knows something
going on either way the document said go
down here for a minute David Copperfield
was at a dinner at Epstein's and there
was another girl pres who looked young
and Joanna asked what school she went to
and Joanna did not recognize the school
name as being a college and she said it
was possible that it was a high school
aged girl Joanna said Copperfield
question me if I was aware that girls
were getting paid to find other
girls M
huh then there's all those weird Notes
too like the jackpot thing we saw
earlier yeah get some of those up David
copperfield's notes when he got to the
island none of this suggests any
wrongdoing David
Copperfield he like and now my trick I
will make these 15-year-old girls uh
disappear so this is weird yeah this is
odd this is an important
message uh Mr David Copperfield this is
for
Jeffrey time
5:36 I guess amm or p.m I can't
see he will be receiving later arriving
later and he will be expecting he'll be
arriving later he will be expecting he
will be arriving later and he will be
expecting for Jeffrey Epstein David
Copperfield the date my birthday January
22nd 2005 I was of course not born in
2005 I was born in uh
1902 but uh the message for Jeffrey
Epstein from
someone speaking on behalf of David
Copperfield
yes it's jackpot right is the message
it's
jackpot I don't know what that means but
I'll tell you this it doesn't suggest
any wrongdoing
it doesn't it doesn't if you just cuz
you've sent a human traffick or a
message of visiting his Island does not
suggest it's NBC is telling you it does
not suggest any wrong D now if Donald
Trump inflate inflates the price of a
condo by 80 grand he should be given the
death penalty but NBC is letting us know
that it's just not that big of a deal
none of this is that big of a deal the
messages the visiting the pretty soon
it's coming where they're going to say
visiting the island was not a thing
either they're gonna go so what yeah
people went to an island that doesn't
mean
anything yes they went to a pedophile
orgy Island but it's not it doesn't mean
that anything was going
on the only one who did anything was
David Copper they're gonna tell they're
gonna come on the TV and they're going
to say that David Copperfield ran this
whole
operation and that Clinton was there to
stop David Copperfield for molesting the
girls that's what we're going to be told
Bill Clinton found out about this and he
went to that Island 25 times to try to
shut it down to try to stop it